what does a day in the life of jordan
peterson look like
which is this very interesting day let's
look at the day when you have to speak
preparing your mind thinking of what
you're going to talk about
preparing yourself physically
mentally to interact with the crowd
through the actual speaking how do you
adjust what you're thinking through and
how do you come down from that so you
can start all again as a limited
biological system
well
i'm usually up by
seven
and ready to go by
seven thirty or eight
coffee
no
no steak and water
how many times a day steak
all that's all i eat how many times
three or four depending on the day steak
and water taking sparkling water
yeah so
gymnastic asceticism man well i did the
proper i i usually just once a day i did
the the proper jordan peterson last
night and just ate two steaks and how
was that it was wonderful
yeah well if you have to only eat one
thing
you know could be worse so anyways i'm
ready to go at eight because we're
generally moving
what does it moving mean
your costs are flying somewhere
okay and we usually use private flights
now because the commercial airlines
aren't reliable enough and you cannot
not make a venue right so that's rule
number one on the tour
you make the show
so everything and then number rule
number two is anybody who causes any
trouble on the tour is gone
because there is zero room for error now
no there's zero room for
unnecessary unaddressed error so because
there's going to be errors the guys i
have around me now
if they make a mistake they fix it right
away
so
and that's great there's a lot of people
relying on you to be there so you have
like like
4 000 people typically yeah so so then
i'm on the plane
and i'm usually i usually write
or often
because there's no
internet on the plane and that's a good
use of time so i'm writing a new book so
i write on the plane typing or
handwriting typing
yeah typing
and uh
then we land and we go to
it's usually early afternoon by then we
go to a hotel it's usually a nice hotel
that's not corporate i don't really like
corporate hotels my secretary and my one
of my logistics guys has got quite good
at picking
kind of adventurous hotels boutique
hotels are usually in the old parts of
the city especially in europe somewhere
interesting
and so we go there
and then
lunch usually
and sometimes that's an air fryer and a
steak in the hotel room and i leave a
trail of air fryers behind me all across
the world
and uh
then
tammy and i usually go out and have a
walk or something and take a look at the
city and then i have a rest for like an
hour and a half or an hour half an hour
like a nap yes now i have to sleep for
20 minutes and that's about all i can
sleep but i need to do that in the late
hour never refreshes your mind yeah that
gives me that wakes me up again for the
evening
and then tam has to sleep longer she's
still recovering from her illness and so
she has to sleep longer in the afternoon
and that's absolutely necessary for both
of us or things start to get frayed
and so then
we go to the venue
and then i usually sit for
an hour
if i'm going to lecture i've been doing
a lot of q and a's and that's a little
easier but if i'm going to lecture i
have to sit for an hour and then i think
okay
what question am i trying to investigate
i have to have that that's the point
what mystery am i trying to
unravel it's usually associated with one
of the rules in my book because
technically it's a book tour but each of
those rules is an investigation into an
ethic
and each of them points to a deeper sort
of mystery in some sense and
there's no end to the amount it can be
explored
and so i have the question
the question might be something like uh
put your
put your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world okay
what does that mean exactly put what
does house mean
what does put
what does put mean that active
verb what does perfect and order mean
why before you criticize the world what
does it mean to criticize what does it
mean to criticize the world how can you
do that properly or improperly so i
start to think about how to decompose
the question and you start to think
which of these decompositions are
important to really dig into yeah well
then they'll strike me it's like okay
there's something there that that i've
been maybe noodling around on that i
would like to investigate further then i
think okay how can i approach this
problem i think well i have this story
that i know i have this story and i have
this story but i haven't juxtaposed them
before and there's going to be some
interesting interaction in the
juxtaposition
so i have the question and i kind of
have a framework of interpretation and
then i have some potential narrative
places i can go and then i think okay i
can go juggle that and see what happens
and so then what i want to do is
concentrate on that process while
attending to the audience to make sure
that the words are landing
and then see if i can delve into it
deeply enough so that a narrative
emerges spontaneously
with an ending now i'm sure you've
experienced this in podcasts right
maybe i'm wrong but my experience has
been if i fall into the conversation
and we know about the time frame
there'll be a natural narrative arc
and then so you'll kind of know when the
midpoint is and you'll kind of see when
you're reaching a conclusion and then if
you really pay attention you can see
that's a good place to stop
it's kind of you come to a point
and
you have to be alert and patient to see
that
and you have to be willing to be
satisfied with where you've got to but
if you do that and then it's like a
comedian making the punch line work it's
like
i've got all these balls in the air
and they're going somewhere
and this is
how they come together and people love
that right they say oh this and this
this and this
whack
together
and that's an insight and it is very
much like a punchline well that's
interesting because your mind actually
some fan of your podcast too and
you are always driving towards that i
would say
for me in in a podcast conversation
there's often a kind of
alice in wonderland type of exploration
down the rabbit hole man and then you
just a new thing pops up and the more
absurd the wilder the better yeah
conversations with elon are like this
yeah it's like actually the more you
drive towards an arc the more
uncomfortable you start to get
in a fun absurd conversation because
oh i i'm now one of the normies no i
don't want that i want to be i want i
want the rabbit i want the crazy
because it makes it more uh
fun but somehow
throughout it there is
wisdom that you try to grasp at well
such that there is a thread well that's
the thing man you're following the
thread eh yeah the thread's right the
thread well that's right that's what
we're trying to do that thread
that thread is the proper balance
between structure and spontaneity and it
manifests itself as the instinctive
meaning and that's the logos in the
dialogues and it really is the logos and
god only knows what that means
you know i mean the biblical claim is
that logos is the fundamental principle
of reality
and i think that's true
i actually think that's true
because i think that that meaning that
guides you well here's a way of thinking
but i've been writing about this
recently
what's real
matter it's like okay that's one answer
what's real
what matters is real
because that's how you act okay so
that's different than matter
it's like okay
what's the most real of what matters
how about pain
why is it the most real
try arguing it away
good luck
so pain is the fundamental reality
all right
well that's rough
doesn't that lead to nihilism and
hopelessness
yeah doesn't it lead to a philosophy
that's antithetical towards being the
most fundamental reality is pain
yes
is there anything more fundamental than
pain
love
really
if you're in pain
love and truth
that's what you got
and you know
if they're more powerful than pain
maybe they're the most real things
when you think about reality what is
real that is the most real thing
well it's a tough one right because you
have to
because if you're a scientist a
materialist think well
the matter is the most real it's like
well you don't know what the matter is
yeah and so and then when push comes to
shove and it will
you'll find out what's most real yeah
i i feel like this is uh
missing
physical reality is is missing some of
the things
so of course pain has a biological
component and all those kinds of things
but it it's missing something deep about
the human condition that
at least the modern science is not able
to
uh describe but it is reaching towards
that yeah it is the reason
one way to describe it as you're
describing is the reason it's reaching
it is because underneath of science is
this assumption that
there's a deep
logos
thing to this whole thing we're trying
to do
well you know there's two traditions
right in some sense there's two logos
traditions
there's the
the greek
rational
enlightenment tradition that's a logos
tradition and it insists that there's a
logos in nature and that science is the
way to approach it and then there's the
judeo-christian logos which is more
embodied and more spiritual and i would
say the west is actually an attempt to
unite those two and it's the proper
attempt to unite those two
because they need to be united
and i see the union coming in near terms
you know i talked to france to wall for
example about the animating principle of
chimpanzee sovereignty
and that's pretty close biologically is
it power
because that's the claim even from the
biologists often the most dominant chimp
has the best reproductive success
it's like
oh yeah dominant dominante you mean
using compulsion okay let's look
are the chimps who use compulsion
the most successful and the answer is
sporadically and rarely
and for short well that's sporadically
for short periods of time why
because they meet an unpleasant end
the subordinates over whom they exercise
arbitrary control
wait for a weak moment and then tear
them into shreds
right
every dictator's terror
and for good reason and dewall has
showed that the alpha chimps the males
who do have preferential mating access
often
are often and reliably
the best peacemakers and the most
reciprocal
and so even among chimps the principle
of sovereignty is something like
iterative iterated
reciprocity and that's a way better
principle than
power
and it's something like i've been
thinking what's the antithesis of the
spirit of power
i think it's the spirit of play
and you know you i don't know what you
think about that but when you have a
good podcast conversation you already
described it in some sense as play it's
like there's a structure right because
it's an ordered conversation but you
want there to be play in the system and
if you get that right then it's really
engaging
and then it seems to have its own
narrative arc i'm not trying to impose
that even though that's another thing i
don't do i didn't come to this
conversation
at all thinking here's what i want out
of a conversation with lex friedman like
instrumentally i thought
i'll go talk to lex why
i like his podcasts
he's doing something right i don't know
what it is he asks interesting questions
i'll go have a conversation with him
where's it gonna go
wherever it goes
embracing the spirit of play
so what you have this
when you're lecturing
you're going in front of the crowd
you thought of a question yeah
you get on the stage first of all are
you nervous at all
i'm very nervous when i'm sitting down
thinking through the structure
initially which is why my wife and i
have been doing q and a's and that's
easier on me yeah it's the uh
it's the the way comedians are nervous
like uh joe rogan just did his special
so this weekend and so he now has to sit
nervously like a comedian does which is
like
i have no material now
right i have to start well
when i was doing the lectures constantly
instead of the q and a's
yes basically what i was doing was
writing a whole book chapter every night
yeah and you know now that's a bit of an
exaggeration because i would return to
themes that i had developed but it's not
really an exaggeration because i didn't
ever
just
go over rote material ever
so it was it's very demanding and that
part's nerve-wracking because i sit down
it's an hour before the show and i think
can i pull can i do this
and you know the answer is well you did
it
a thousand times
but that's not this time yeah it's like
can i come up with a question can i
think through the structure can i pull
off the
spontaneous
narrative can i pull it together and the
answer is i don't know
and so then i get it together in my mind
i think and that's hard it takes effort
and it's nerve-racking
okay i got it but then there's the
moment you go out on stage and you think
well i know i had it but can i do it no
notes
and then the question is well you're
gonna find out well you do it
and so then i go out on stage
and i don't talk to the audience
i talk to one person at a time
and you can talk to one person you know
because you know how to do that so i
talk to a person and not too long
because i don't want to make them too
nervous and then someone else and
someone else and then i'm in contact
with the audience and then i can tell
if the words are landing and i listen
it's like are they wrestling around
are they dead quiet because they want
dead quiet
you're so i see that's what focus sounds
like you're you're in it together then
you bet well and i also here's a good
rule if you're learning to speak
publicly i never say a word
till everyone is 100
quiet
and that's it's a great way to start a
talk because
you're set in the frame and if the frame
is well i'll talk while you're talking
the message is
well you can talk
this is a place where everybody can talk
it's like no it's not
this is a place where people paid to
hear me talk so i'm not going to talk
till everyone's listening
and so
then you get that stillness
and then you just wait because that
stillness turns into an expectation and
then it comes turns into a kind of
nervous expectations like what the hell
is he doing it's not manipulative it's a
sense of timing it's like just when
that's right you think okay now it's
time to start well that nerve the
interesting thing about that nervous
expectation is from an audience
perspective we're in it together
yeah i mean there is into that silence
there's a togetherness to it of course
it's the union of everyone's attention
yeah yeah and that's and that's a great
thing i mean you love that at a concert
when everyone it's not silence then but
when everyone's attention is unified and
everyone's moving in unison it's like
we're all worshiping the same thing
right it's when that would be the point
of the conversation the point of the
lecture and the worship is the direction
of attention towards it and it's uni
it's communion because everyone's doing
it at the same time
and so
i mean there's not much difference
between lecture theater and the church
in that regard right it's the same
fundamental layout and structure and
they're very integrally associated with
one another one really grew out of the
other the lecture theater grew out of
the church
so it's it's perfectly reasonable to be
thinking about it in those terms
and so and then okay so after
the lecture we play a piece of music
that is a piece of music that i've been
producing with some musicians for
a couple of books i'm going to release
in the fall terrible books abc of
childhood tragedy they're called dark
dark books
dark and comical books
terrible books
heartbreaking illustrations
we've set them to music and so we play a
piece from that and then afterwards i
usually meet about 150 people
to have photographs and
so each of those is a little is there a
little sparkle of human connection a lot
a lot it's it's very intense
10 seconds with every person you think
how can 10 seconds be intense it's like
pay enough attention because it gets
intense real quick does it break your
heart to say goodbye so many times
it's like being at a in a wedding lineup
at a wedding that you want to be at
and everybody's dressed up
and that's so weird eh because i bought
these expensive suits when i went on
tour and it broke my heart because i
spent so much money on them i thought
god that's completely unconscionable i
thought no way man
yeah i'm in this 100
and so i'm gonna dress with respect
and
like sixty percent of the audience comes
in two or three piece suits they're all
dressed up
then there's this line to greet me and
they're all happy to see me
that's not so hard to take you know
although it is in a sense right because
normal interactions are pretty shallow
and you think i don't want shallow
interactions like yes you do most of the
time yeah
it's intense it's very intense and i
don't know if you've had a taste of this
no doubt because people recognize yeah
but i also have um
when a person recognizes me and they
come with the love and they're often
brilliant people
one of the thoughts i have to deal with
one of the dragons in my own mind is
you know thinking that i don't deserve
that kind of attention
and so well you probably don't
right
it's a burden in that i have to step up
to be the kind of person that deserves
that that deserves that but in part
deserves that kind of intention and
that's like
holy [ __ ] it's crucially important too
because
if someone comes up to you in an airport
and they know who you are and they're
brave enough to admire you or who you
are attempting to be and you
make a mistake
they will never
forget it yeah so it's a high-stakes
enterprise and the flip side of that
especially with young people
a few words you can say can change the
direction of their life one way or
another
and so i really have to watch this too
in airports because i do not like
airports i do not like the creeping
totalitarianism in airports they've
always bothered me yes they really
bother me
and i'm an unpleasant travel companion
for my wife sometimes because of that
although i think we've worked that out
thank god because we're doing a lot of
traveling but
most of the security guards and and the
border personnel all those people they
know me and as a general rule they're
positively predisposed to me and so if
i'm peevish or irritable
yeah then
well that's not good
it's not good and so that's a tight rope
to walk to because i do not like that
creeping totalitarianism but by the same
token
you know
if you're just one of the crowd just
you know sometimes you it's good just to
be one of the crowd and then you're a
little irritable and people can just
brush that off but if you're someone
they have dared to
open their heart to because that's what
admiration is and then you're
be and you betray that
then
that's a real they'll never forget it
and then they'll tell everyone too
so
it takes a lot of alertness and so tammy
in our life has got complicated because
in toronto for example
we can't really just go for a walk
it's always a high drama production
because always people come up and they
have some
heart-rending story to tell and i'm not
being cynical about that yes
it's a hard thing to
bear because people don't do that they
don't just open themselves up to you
like that share the tragedy of their
life
but that's an everyday occurrence and so
when we go up to our cottage which is
out of the city
it's a relief you know because
as wonderful as that is like it's a
weird i have a weird life because
everywhere i go it's very weird it's
like i'm surrounded by old friends
because i walk down the street in any
city now virtually and people say hello
dr peterson so nice to see you or they
say better things than that very rarely
bad things one
one experience in 5 000 may be very rare
although you don't forget those either
but it's very it's very strange
so and there's an intimacy they know you
well and and because they leap into
uh they avoid the small talk often they
leap into familiarity it really is like
it's an old friend and it feels like
that for me personally the experience is
the goodbye hurts
because um
you know there's a sense where you're
never gonna see that friend again right
yeah that's a strange thing eh so to me
a lot of the uh
a lot of it just feels like goodbyes
come on it is
you're right about that and i mean
that's i suppose in some sense
part of the pain of opening yourself up
to people because they also
tammy has been struck particularly she
said i really never knew what men were
like i said well what do you mean
she said i cannot believe how polite
the men are when they come and talk to
you because it's always the same the
pattern's very similar the person comes
up they're mostly men not always but
mostly
and they're tentative and they're very
polite very very polite and they say i
hope i'm not bothering you do you mind
you know do you mind that i say that
they're not bothering me
and i'm doing everything i can to not be
the guy who's bothered by that it's like
who do you think you are yeah
yes you're the guy that
what is famous and now is above that
yeah
you don't want to be that guy yeah so
you want to be grateful all the time
when people open up like that
and and so you got to be alert and on
point to do that properly like right
away because
for these for you it's five seconds or
10 seconds or 20 seconds whatever it is
but for them
they've opened up and so you can really
nail them if you're foolish
after the 150 people how do you come
down from that how do you
how do you find yourself
again well that was awesome when i got
taught caught in twitter traps
you know because i'm so burnt out by
then
from the from the talk and the
and the audience interactions and the
whole day because it's a new city it's a
new hotel it's it's a new 5 000 people
it's a new book chapter it's a whole new
horizon of ideas and it's off to another
city the next day
i'm so burnt out by then that
i'm not as good at
controlling my impulses as i might be
and twitter was a real catastrophe for
that because it would hook me and then i
couldn't
like i used to when i was working on my
book
a lot i used to call tammy and say look
you have to come and get me i can't stop
i can't stop i got tired and then i kind
of because it's part of a kind of
hypomanic focus i couldn't quit it's
like oh no i i'm still writing i need to
get away from this but i couldn't stop
and so
it's better to
to read something
a book
fiction non-fiction fiction
stephen king i was reading a lot of
stephen king when i was on tour last
time that was good i like stephen king a
lot of great narratives great and great
characterization
you know
so and
there's a familiarity about stephen
king's
writing too that it's he writes about
people you know
and so i really found that a relief
and so that was useful
and that in order to tolerate this let's
say or to be able to sustain it
well let's take a lot of negotiation on
the part of tammy and i because
she's dragged into this and
you know her life is
part of this whatever this is and she's
had to find her way and has for example
now she has a different hotel room than
me when we travel
and she she found that she didn't want
to be on the tour this spring and i was
ill again for part of it not made it
complicated but
she went away back home and she came
back and she said she was nervous but
she said i think i need my own room and
part of me was not happy with that it's
like what do you mean you need your like
are we not married anymore it's like you
need your own room
and she said well you know i can't
she has to do exercises because she was
really sick and she has to keep herself
in shape
and she has to have some time to do that
she does a lot of prayer and meditation
and she needs the time and she has her
own podcast which is going quite well
and she needs the time and
and i trust her and she said well i need
this
in order to continue and i thought well
okay
if you need this in order to continue
yes because she went away and didn't say
well i i don't want to be on the tour i
don't want to do this anymore she went
away and prayed let's say
how can i continue to do this
and that was the answer and so she has
her own hotel room and
that was a really good decision on her
part and she's very good
and getting better all the time at
figuring out
what has to happen for her to make this
sustainable and all that's been is a
plus
because
i don't want to travel without her and
and i don't want her life to be
miserable and i want her to be fully on
board and so she has to be properly
selfish
like everyone does in a relationship and
you have to
not just that yet this is a weird thing
that you're doing and you have to
both you and her have to figure out how
to like how to manage this very intense
intellectual well
there's another element to it too that i
didn't tell you about so that was a
typical day but it's missing a big
component because usually we also have a
dinner
with like 30
cultural representatives i suppose
10 to 30 from each country because i
have a network of people who have
networks
who are setting me up with key decision
makers in each country
and so then we have like an hour and a
half of that now sometimes that's on a
day when i don't have a talk if we but
sometimes the talks are back to back
and so
she also has to
manage that and to be gracious and and
then people are showing us exciting
things and tours in the cities and which
is all like it's a surf fight of
wonderful yes exactly but you're it's
still yeah you have to be there for you
have to be present for it mentally yeah
as a curious mind as an intellectual
mind how do you uh how do you get to
sleep
fortunately
that is almost never a problem even when
i was
unbelievably ill
for about three years
i thought about that a lot too you know
that i didn't do a really good job of
explaining that while i was ill because
it appeared in some sense that the
reason i was ill was because i was
taking benzodiazepines but that isn't
why
i was ill and then i took them and very
low dose and i took that for a long time
and it helped whatever was wrong with me
and it looks like it was an allergy
or maybe multiple allergies
and then
that stopped working and so i took a
little bit more for about a month and
that made it way worse and so then i cut
back a lot and then
then things really got out of hand and
so so there was a deeper thing
oh yeah
oh yeah what can you put words to
well i had a lot of immune my my
daughter as everyone knows has a very
reactive immune system and tammy has
three immunological conditions
each of them quite serious and i had
psoriasis and peripheral uveitis which
is an autoimmune condition and alopecia
areata and
chronic gum disease all of which
appeared to be elderly related and so
michaela seems to have got all of that
and so that and that i think was at the
bottom of because i also had this
proclivity to depression that was part
of my family history but i think that
was all immunological as far as i can
tell so one of the things that's
happened to me
i always noticed i really couldn't
breathe
like i could breathe about one-fifth as
much as i
sometimes could
and so i was always short of breath and
it looks like what that was perhaps was
i was always on the border of an
anaphylactic reaction
which is not pleasant
and that's hypersympathetic activation
no parasympathetic activation i couldn't
relax
at all that's a immunological response
allergic response yeah
so anyways that was what seemed now this
i don't like to talk about this much
because it's so bloody radical and you
know i don't like to propagate it but
this diet seems to have stopped all of
that i don't have psoriasis all of the
patches have gone yeah my gum disease
which is incurable i had multiple
surgeries to deal with it is completely
gone took three years my right eye which
was quite cloudy it's cleared up
completely
um
[Music]
what else has changed well i lost 50
pounds and
like instantly kept it off i should
mention that i i i too am not a deep
investigator of uh nutritional science i
have my skepticism towards the degree to
which it is currently as a science
because like a lot of complex systems
it's very it's full of mystery
uh and full of uh
profiteers the people that profit of
different kinds of diets but i should
say for me personally it does seem that
i feel
by far the best when i eat only meat
it's very interesting and i discovered
that it's really a long time ago first
of all how do you discover it uh so by
the the discovery went like this i
started listening to ultra marathon
runners about
15 years ago
and they started talking about
fat adapted
running
so i first discovered that i don't have
to run super fast to enjoy running and
in fact i really enjoy running at a
slower pace
um so that was like step one's like oh
okay if i maintain
something called the
the math rule which is
a pretty low heart rate if i maintain
that you can actually get pretty fast
while maintaining a pretty slow average
speed in general anyway they fuel
themselves on low carb diets
so i got into that
on top of that i also they also fast
often so i discovered how incredible my
mind feels
when fasted you know people call it
intermittent fasting but well that's an
optimization of death eh because you're
when you fast your body
logically and obviously if you think
about it biologically is well what does
your body scavenge first well
damaged tissue
so
the the i know the literature on fasting
to some degree and it's it's very
compelling literature if you if you
starve dogs down i think it's 20 below
rats too below their optimal body weight
they live 30 percent longer
yeah
that's a lot 30 like it's like 30
percent yeah yeah 30 percent well there
there is aspect to a lot of these things
that make me nervous because
i always feel like there's no free lunch
that i'm gonna pay for it somehow but
there is a focus that i am able to
attain when i fast
especially when i eat once a day
my mind is almost like nervously focused
it's almost like an anxiety but a
positive one or one that i can channel
into just like an excitement you know i
wonder how much of that's associated
with
well imagine that
that signifies lack of food which not
that hard to imagine well maybe you
should be a lot more alert in that
situation right biologically speaking
because you're in hunting mode let's say
you know not desperate but in hunting
mode and god only knows
maybe human beings should be in hunting
mode all the time often but that we
don't know that so i wonder if it has
uh a
stress on the system that long term
causes the system to doesn't it doesn't
look like it it it seems in case of
fasting not and then on top of that i
discovered that the thing i enjoy i just
don't enjoy eating
fat as much
so i i love eating meat and when you
talk about low carb diets so i just
discovered through that process if
someone fatted me but just me i just
feel
a lot of the things that make me feel
weird about food like a little groggy or
like full or just
whatever
the aspects of food that i don't enjoy
they're not there with meat and i'm
still able to enjoy company and when i
eat once a day
and eat meat
at least in texas
you could still have all the merriment
oh yeah
you have dinner with friends now i don't
do the uh this you know you have a very
serious thing
that
um
there's health benefits that you are
very serious about for me i can still
drink whiskey
i'll still do the things that add a
little bit of
spice spice into the thing yeah now when
you completely remove the spice it it
does become more difficult yeah it's
more difficult socially and tammy seems
to only be able to eat lamb although she
might be able to eat non-aged beef and
that makes traveling complicated too
right because
well for obvious reasons it's like
really that's all you can eat
yeah well c'est la vie and maybe that's
a form of craziness but
you